at the top of the show yesterday i
wondered what the o
sound was that plays in the beginning of
our great american nightmare theme song
by rob zombie here is the sound i am
talking about
that little oh oh
oh oh like somebody got caught by
surprise doing something oh
yeah right exactly now here it is
isolated so you can hear what i'm
talking about
most people who wrote thought it was a
drop of the late comedian sam kinnison
which would have made sense that when
rob created the song he knows our show
he knows how much we loved sam and how
many times we had sam kinnison on this
was the theory that it came from the sam
kinnison scream
there's sam that's that's actually sam
and then you know
could be
but i think this theory is better and i
think this theory is completely right on
the noise at the beginning of the theme
song is the end of pig vomit's rant from
the movie private parts
when he ends his rant with howard stern
can kiss my ass in hell
it goes right into the theme song so
you're hearing the l how about that
howard stern huh [ __ ]
howard stanley kissed my ass in the hell
[Music]
and it goes right in the hell
if you listen to it carefully
hell they help
so that is from this private part
soundtrack what it sounds like to me is
that isn't part of rob's song that when
we pulled that off the soundtrack album
so that we'd have a song for the front
of the show
it sounds like somebody who did the edit
left the hell in they did a poor edit
now i realize that might not even or
maybe such a close edit they might not
have been able to slice it out without
bothering the music you think
i was a production director let me
listen carefully i'll tell you if i
could have gotten that out
the song is that static
no i could have done it i uh i used this
gotten rid of the stats
you would have no left out the static i
would have left out the l
out the hell part
is right there with the l
i don't i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about with static i'm
talking about hell i'm talking about i
could have gotten that out it shouldn't
be there sound that's part of the song
that's right then let me hear you
[Music]
it's not
that no no no i know what you mean no
that is part of the background noise pig
vomit is outside in the street
uh and that that l is over the the noise
you're referring to yes i see this is a
negative
that is an accident of poor editing it
happens to sound pretty cool
yeah sounds like i'd be part of the song
but i guarantee it if we asked rob he'd
say no i didn't put that in you guys for
some reason when you play it have that i
wonder if that bothers him
well it's going to bother the [ __ ] out
of me now and i want to go back in and
remove the l i'll do it personally